with gaussian elimination
That's what we're going to talk about now.
gaussian elimination
we can use these Matrix we can use.
one row
to either
and we usually would eliminate okay to when you get your
Matrix in reduced row Echelon form
you have eliminated the rows.
To eliminate means well again you have leading ones
on you have ones on the principal diagonal zeros.
below the principal Diagon
so in order for us to eliminate
these rows we can use them against each other.
So, for example, I can take row number two.
Subtract it from row number one or vice versa,
or I can multiply one of these rows
by some other number.
and then
that rule
Whose values have now become multiples of some other number I
can subtract from the first row.
This one should be difficult to do so for example and just
again for notational convenience.
I'm going to lose.
That 10 to the power 4 and I
hope you're okay with that. I'm just gonna lose that because you know the separate the
notation.
the easier will be for us to
keep track of what's going on.
and I'm going to lose this parenthesis really get
all that clutter out of the way.
So again, I want this to be a leading one.
And you know what just to simplify
this so we don't spend too much time. I'm going to reorder these and that's
perfectly fine. The that's within
Gauss and elimination. You can swap rows.
Okay. Anyway, I what I've done is I've now
swapped.
the rules in fact to denote this
we would do we would say this r
sub 2
and then a right arrow.
R sub 1
That means R2 has been replaced with R1.
now in your opinion
How can I
Get this to be reduced.
Assume this was two.
This was one and this was one and one.
What would we have to do to reduce this to
eliminate this role?
Well, I would say we would subtract Row 2
from Row 1.
so the difference of this row and
that row and then the
Result of that difference. I would put back into Row
1.
Let me show you what I mean. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to subtract Row
2 from Row 1.
and the order is important right because
If I subtract 200 minus 100, I'll get
a positive number. Whereas I'll get
a negative number the other that we round so I'm going to subtract row two from Row
and then I'm going to take this evaluation.
This result and replace it with the Row 1 so
I will get something that looks like this.
This becomes 100.
So 200 minus 100 gives you
100.
Minus 100 this is gonna give me zero.
And then 4,000 minus 3,000 that's
gonna give me one thousand.
There we go. So I have 100 up
here.
Now I need to get this.
To be a zero.
Okay.
We're doing gaussian elimination.
Now, let's see how I can get rid of that. I can subtract. Well, well
100 minus 100 and this will this
I will subtract.
This Row from that row and
then the result.
I will plug it inside Row 1.
But if I subtract this from that I'm going to get in. I'm
going to get a negative 2,000. I don't want negative 2000 so I'll do
roll one minus row two, so I'm going
to go.
Row 1
minus Row 2
and then whatever the evaluates to I'm going to plug that into Row
1.
So we will get something that looks like this.
Okay, 100 minus 100. That's just
zero.
100 minus 100 that will stay 100
and then 3000 minus 1,000 that
gives us 2,000.
Look at that.
now we have
upper triangle
The last thing I need to do is get these to be once.
And what I will do is I will multiply this by
one over 100.
So I'll cancel them out.
So to denote that.
step
I'm going to say.
that I will multiply
I will multiply.
all the numbers on Row 1 with 1 over
and then
I'm going to
replace Row 1
with the result of this
calculation right arrow
so that will do what it will give me.
100 over 100
100 over 100. That's just one.
Zero over 100. That's just zero and then 1,000 over
100 is just 10.
And then I'm going to do the same thing for row number two, so I'm going to copy this
bit.
Okay.
I'm gonna do the same thing for row number
two.
Okay.
multiply these values
with one over 100
and then this is what's going to happen.
So 0 over 100 this is going to be zero.
That's going to be 1.
And then 2,000 over 100 is going to be 20.
And of course, I hope you can see the solution. It's with managed
to do it if I
Put back.
the
You know.
times 10 to the power 4
Well, we'll get this Matrix.
This one sorry but 10 to the power 4.
times 10 to the power 4
times 10
to the power 4
This is exactly what we had seen in our
last session.
Right. So what is this if we plug in
these values back into the
Inequalities we had this would give us or
after we turned ecology the equations we would
get One X.
plus 0 y equals 10
times
10 to the power 4 which is 10 million.
And then for the one below.
the one below this would become zero X
1 y
times 10 to the power 4
and of course if we get rid of these zeros, I'm only putting the
leading one just so you can see how I imply like
what I'm plugging these numbers.
but in algebra, of course, we don't actually put
one
we don't put the coefficient one.
That because that that's implied it's there. So the
one goes away.
0 y That's Just well, that's nothing
that goes away.
And here down here zero X so the
X goes away.
And then one y we don't actually need to put the Y we don't need to
put the one and there we go. That's exactly what we have. This is the this was
the the point on the feasible region.
so
we looked at we have now seen two ways of solving our system
inequalities one was.
with the
Classical algebra and now we've used Gauss elimination
from linear algebra.
now
In my opinion, this is still time consuming right? I
do think
would you say this is simpler than
the algebraic manipulation we saw
in our last session or easier.
so gaussian elimination versus
Classical object which one do you think is easier?
There Was the Same
I suppose.
I would say however if you're doing multiple inequalities, your
gaussian will will be more will
be a lot faster.
Which is more organized I agree because you don't have to move things
to the left to the right.
Well, yeah.
I think with some practice you might find.
Galaxy elimination furthermore. Here's another
thing.
You probably won't do this by hand in real life.
Like if you have an actual LP problem and you
have to solve system of equations, you're not gonna do this by hand that will
be ridiculous. Right? We have calculators now.
They calculate to which I'm referring are casts.
CIS computer algebra system
You know like TX, Texas Instruments makes
them you would plug in your you would
type in your equation.
Then say software Excel for y and you will get the roots.
Or you could but if you have like many constraints are
caste system is going is not going to be useful. So
you want to use something like Matlab or numpy to
solve many system of equations.
So in in the in the real world calculation,
or at least led the
composition which we'll get to is going to be far.
for a more efficient approach and
classical logic
and exactly. Yes, you do need to plan a plan of
attack, but you have to sit down and think through it whereas
with Technologies like Matlab and
libraries like numpy you just
Write a line of code and you have the solution.
Okay.
But I hope you you now see what we have done.
You know understand Galaxy elimination.